[Music]
you're watching the press preview it's
the first look at what is on the front
pages it's time to check out the
headlines with the deputy editor of
concern with home henry hill and the
senior associate editor for the new
statesman rachel kunliff they'll be with
us from now until just before midnight
so let's take a look at some of those
front pages before we chat to them
starting with the metro remarking on the
increasing number of letters of no
confidence lodged against the prime
minister by his fellow tory mps their
headline boris may be toast
the telegraph says mr johnson's own
ethics adviser lord guyt has exp asked
for him to explain why he believes he
hasn't broken the ministerial code
the eye reports that the prime minister
has been making phone calls to mps in an
effort to shore up support in a possible
no-confidence vote
the mirror goes with the archbishop of
canterbury suggesting prince andrew is
trying to make amends and he should be
forgiven after settling his sex abuse
case
here's your guardian focusing on the
fact that criminal acts of violence at
gp surgeries across the uk have almost
doubled in five years as doctors leaders
warn of a perfect storm of soaring
demand and staff shortages
the ft has word of a pact between the uk
and the eu banning the insurance of
ships carrying russian oil which
effectively stops russia's ability to
export crude oil altogether
and don't forget by scanning the qr code
you can see on screen during the
programme you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us discussing them and i'm joined
tonight by henry hill and rachel
cunliffe great to see you both thanks
for joining us so
rachel perhaps we can start with the
front page of the metro their headline
pretty start for the prime minister
boris maybe toast there are rumors uh
that uh potentially all the letters
required those 54 letters are already in
i mean do you think it's a case of when
as opposed to if well it's not going to
be before the bank holiday jubilee
weekend i think we can all count on that
but one thing that the the conservative
party really doesn't want is to
overshadow those celebrations that you
were reporting on just a moment ago
people camping outside buckingham palace
so we're not going to hear anything
until next week but yes those who have
been keeping a close eye on numbers uh
now say that the ones that we know about
uh
30 letters or at least 30 mps who have
spoken out suggest that it's it's highly
likely that we have hit 54 letters and
if we haven't hit them yet we're going
to hit them pretty soon which i think is
very interesting because if i'd been on
this show a week ago we'd have been
talking about the imminent
uh publication of the sue grey report if
i'd been on on wednesday night we've
been talking about how the sue grey
report was published and how uh the
prime minister seemed to have got away
with that um and
without
any dramatic interventions in parliament
and the whole thing was a bit of a damp
squib uh and yet here we are and
according to the metro he's toast yeah
rachel do you think it's interesting
that isn't it i wonder why the delay
from when sue grey uh published her
report to now do you think
many uh including journalists actually
some journalists sort of misread the
mood and thought that boris johnson was
safer than maybe he is
i think a couple of things may have
happened one of them is that tory mps
went back to their uh constituencies uh
at the end of last week and
maybe faced some very angry constituents
who asked what they were going to do
about it obviously they have been using
the excuse up till now we'll wait until
the met investigation is complete and
we'll wait until two grey reports is
published they don't have either of
those excuses anymore so maybe they they
started to really feel the heat i do
also get the sense that this drip drip
drip of letters with no confidence and
interventions uh may well have been
coordinated
by conservative mps who want johnson out
who maybe figured that they could get
more mileage out of their letters if
they kept the pressure on over a
prolonged period of time rather than
sort of dramatically all saying it at
once but certainly we are in a very
different position now than we were six
days ago yeah and it's interesting that
that the language even seems to have
changed a little bit tonight henry
doesn't it just look at the front page
of the eye they're claiming this is an
exclusive that the prime minister is
phoning tory mps to save his job and sky
news spoke to nadine doris earlier on
today a huge supporter of course of of
boris johnson and she wasn't talking in
terms of the number of letters but
rather in the number of supporters that
the prime minister would have if there
is a vote so
a a a shift there in the language
yeah absolutely it does seem as though
we are going to finally get the tory
leadership contest which has been
brewing or at least a leadership
challenge which has been brewing for a
while now i think i don't think at this
point journalists or commentators or
observers could have been blamed for
you know not thinking that tory mps
would go through with it they've been
marching up and down this hill in ones
and twos for months there was this
initial surge of interest when partygate
first broke we thought that there was
going to be a challenge then but they
backed down even really high-profile
critics like douglas ross the leader of
the scottish conservatives very visibly
reconciled and kissed the ring and so it
looked as if based on the internal
dynamics of the parliamentary party the
prime minister was going to hold on even
though if you actually look at the
polling for the government and his
personal ratings this story has clearly
done huge damage but it does seem that
for a while now we've had lots of
unhappy tory mps and foxholes maybe not
coordinating worried about going over
the top it does seem now as if they're
starting to realize that there are
enough of them and that they're going to
go for it they're going to go ahead and
do it yeah it's interesting you talk
about the uh the various different um uh
uh factions that that that are coming
together in the fact that it isn't
particularly uh coordinated um uh rather
different to uh to a very coordinated
campaign by the erg when it came to
theresa may and a vote of no confidence
henry
absolutely absolutely the dynamic is
completely different and part of the
reason for that is because i've ever
especially since the collapse of rishi
sunak who until a few weeks ago was the
conservative party they are apparent and
had by far the most developed leadership
challenge machine
um there simply isn't the machinery
they're pushing for boris johnson to go
because there's two stages if you like
to the sort of this kind of instability
the first is when the various candidates
start putting together sounding out
supporters building up their network
putting their infrastructure in place
their shadow whipping operation and all
the rest of it but the second is when
they go on the attack and they start
telling their supporters to put letters
in try and encourage other people to put
letters in now i don't think certainly i
don't think even now probably but
certainly not until very recently that
second stage hasn't been happening which
means that the prime minister has not
faced a coordinated attack by one of his
rivals but maybe dissatisfied mps in
drips and droughts
let's have a look right at the front
page of the daily mail they're going
with rebels without a clue
saying that allies of the prime minister
warned the plotters they could destroy
the conservative party's best chance of
winning the next election because boris
johnson is a vote winner and there's no
obvious successor
well there's a lot going on there isn't
there i mean some people might say that
the conservative party needs to lose an
election that's been in power for 12
years it's it's ideologically drifting
it doesn't seem to know what it is or
what it stands for is it the small state
tax cutting
pro-market party or is it something much
wider that's to do with leveling up but
then how do you do leveling up if you
have to increase taxes are we global
britain are we closing our borders are
we sending uh immigrants to to rwanda
like there's a lot of confusion at the
moment about what the conservative party
is and what it stands for partly because
it has had various different leaders
over that time and it's just a bit tired
and sometimes parties really do need a
period of time outside government to
really remember what it is that they
they stand for but even if you you are a
conservative and you don't think they
need to lose the next election you'd
really quite like to to remain in power
um
you still have the question of whether
boris johnson is the right leader to do
that and the polling is interesting here
i mean that two-thirds of the british
public think that
he should resign over party gate there
are a lot of conservative mps who are
very worried about losing their seats
and crucially they're not one type of
conservative mp you've got conservatives
in the so-called blue wall in the
traditional tory heartlands who are
worried about losing their seats to
liberal democrats you've got the the red
wall seats that boris johnson won you
know he won in places of the country
that no other conservative leader could
have done but they're looking a little
bit rocky now at the moment and you've
got two by-elections coming up on the
23rd of june brexit anniversary or
referendum day anniversary uh that
represent those those two extremes one
in in tibetan and hunterton which is
bluewall one in in wakefield which is
redwall and you're going to see playing
out in action whether boris johnson
really is the vote winner that his
supporters such as nadine doris claim
that he is okay um and i just want to
bring the front page of the daily
telegraph henry because there's another
angle to all of this tonight the ethics
adviser lord geit who advises the prime
minister of course he's brought out his
annual report and he's saying there is a
legitimate question about whether or not
the prime minister broke the ministerial
code when he was
fined um it it just adds to uh to to
boris johnson's concerns doesn't it
it does i think that there's an extent
to which anyone who's actually deeply
familiar with the ministerial code has
to sort of bite their fists when it
comes up in the in the press because the
ministry of code really is a guideline
of expectations for cat for ministers
and it is upheld by boris johnson um so
the question of whether bryce johnson
broke the ministerial code
constitutionally is somewhat irrelevant
but it would certainly be the case that
if he if lord guy ruled that he did it
might encourage more conservative mps to
go over the top and it would encourage
this sense this pervasive sense now that
this is a downing street operation which
is just falling apart the prime minister
cannot shake this story tory mps have
given him a lot of time he simply cannot
pivot away from it and he's also not
getting anything done i think this is
the other thing that is frustrating a
lot of tory mps
you know the the the die-hards who
rallied around margaret thatcher during
that epic showdown at the end of her
premiership you know why they did that
whether or not you think they're right
or wrong she had a clear program that
they believed in and they were prepared
to go to the wall to defend it i think
the thing is if you don't like boris
johnson personally
what
what are you loyal to what is the
project that he's supposed to be
delivering he's backed off planning
reform leveling up doesn't really mean
anything that the war in ukraine would
tick along fine under any prime minister
basically um there's no obvious reason
to keep him in post and i think that's
coming back to buy him and henry we're
out of time but i just want you to
answer this in one sentence you've got
your finger on the pulse if there is a
vote will he win it
if they trickle over the line i suspect
he might win it but if they go over with
a big with a big number then probably
then perhaps not okay interesting stay
where you are because coming up could
the chaos that we've seen at airports
get even worse and what might be done to
stop it we'll be chatting about that
next
[Music]
welcome back part two of the press
preview uh rachel let's talk about the
travel chaos that
many are really suffering with this
half-term holiday and it's interesting
isn't it the travel industry is blaming
the government the government is blaming
the industry
the government is blaming the industry
although the government hasn't actually
had very much to say about this up until
now it seems a bit delayed i mean where
has grant chapster the transport
secretary been not sure uh but
what seems to have happened is that uh
airlines and airports and the aviation
sector
had to lay off a lot of people or made
job cuts during the pandemic when no one
was traveling when they were allowed to
travel and particularly when the travel
rules were changing basically overnight
with with no warning whatsoever for
either passengers or for the industry uh
now
the world is going getting back to
normal slowly there's a huge amount of
demand over easter uh and again now over
over school half term and the jubilee
long weekend and they don't have the
people to bring back so part of it is
well you probably could have predicted
that maybe during school holidays more
people would would like to go away like
seems kind of obvious but part of it is
also these are long-term challenges in
the industry partly as a result of the
pandemic partly dare we say it because
of brexit a lot of european workers who
who went home and the message from from
the industry and from unions that it's
going to get worse before it gets better
sadly does seem to be the case and there
isn't really that much the government
can do about it yeah really tough isn't
it especially for people who've not been
able to have a foreign holiday for a
couple of years desperate to get away
and and now really struggling let's
finish on some good news shall we henry
something to celebrate and cheer about
the platinum jubilee a lovely double
page spread in the metro get this party
started um i think it's going to be fun
isn't it
i think so uh
one of the nice things about the
monarchy is that it's a very sort of
non-partisan
uh repository of sort of rituals which
means that apart from about 20 15 20 of
the population who are republicans most
of the rest of us can uh just get on
with things and enjoy a fun short
working week and long weekend i um
unfortunately i suppose i'm actually one
of those desperate people who's watching
the travel news very carefully because
i'm flying out in the very early hours
of friday morning um but i'm sure that
across the country it's going to be it's
going to be a very enjoyable
way to celebrate an extraordinary what
has been an absolutely extraordinary
life in public service uh for her
majesty oh there's no travel disruption
for that raf fly past uh on thursday
that would be miserable wouldn't it um
henry rachel thank you both very much